[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon welcome thanks welcome to
this event about about cryptography you
know we often think about code breaking
and and this sort of thing as being a
bit of a James Bond style thing we use
it in Wars we use it in in bombs we
think of it as very glamorous a Harry
Houdini kind of experience in reality of
course in the world today in a world as
digital and interconnected as as ours is
it's now all around us it's just into
woven into the fabric of our lives you
know every time you go online every time
you use your ATM card every time you use
a credit card every time you swipe up a
metro card you're relying on the
encryption of that information it's been
said that with the possible exception of
nuclear weapons cryptography is the most
important technology from a political
and economic standpoint we're here with
four of the people who are really
leading the world in all of this just to
find out where this came from where
we're at and where it's going it's we're
gonna look at you know what cryptography
does for us every day whether it's
keeping us safe whether it's keeping our
private information private and our data
secure the panel is fantastic so without
any further ado let's introduce them
Simon Singh is a science writer and
producer he works with the BBC he's the
author of the code book which is a
history of cryptography if you haven't
read his books the Big Bang and firmers
enigma you must fit two of the best
science books that I've read and he's
involved with the Enigma project which
helps bring code breaking to life for
students please welcome Simon Singh
Simon
daddy or Dunkleman is a faculty member
at the University of Haifa in Israel and
is a modern-day Code Breaker he has also
published numerous papers analyzing the
security of ciphers and crypto systems
please welcome or Dunkleman Tao a bin
leads the cryptography research group at
IBM's TJ Watson Research Center that is
considered one of the world's leading
cryptographic research teams she's an
expert in the security of distributed
systems and she's an editor of the
Journal of cryptology please welcome Tom
Tom now Brian snow last but certainly
not least is a former technical director
with the National Security Agency the
NSA it says in my notes that the NSA is
a Cryptologic intelligence agency at the
Department of Defense but that is a bit
like saying that the Department of
Defense is a minor security outfit
underneath the United States government
the NSA is important probably the
biggest operation to spy on electronic
communications worldwide in the States
after retiring in 2006 snow is now a
security consultant and an ethics
adviser please welcome Brian snow
now let's let's sort of begin with the
history and the dawn of cryptography you
know have it how did this begin what
happened I guess the best place to start
is assignment with you where did this
begin I think as soon as you start
writing down anything important whether
it's for example we have cuneiform
encryption of pottery glazes we have
financial transactions encrypted we have
ancient Greek encryption so the ancient
Hebrew texts have have codes in them the
Karma Sutra had an encryption recipe
that women were supposed to learn in
order to encrypt their their love
letters so as soon as you've got
something precious to hide then someone
else is going to want to steal it so you
encrypt it eventually they work at how
to crack your encryption so then you
have to come up with a better form of
encryption and that carries on for 2,000
years and we've been chasing a tail like
that ever since yeah is there a point at
which we really get to somewhere where
there is there's a sort of quantum leap
in how good well we're able to do this
I think the key stages are first of all
the kind of code we might use at school
where we substitute a letter for a
symbol so a becomes a diamond B becomes
a cross and so on and usually about the
extent of my understanding of
cryptography I was just actually I just
organized a bachelor party weekend for
my brother and I didn't want to tell him
where it was we were going to Munich so
I sent him an email with like a letter
number corresponds like Josh I got that
in a second it was like the number to
let out well for 1,500 years people
couldn't crack that kind of code and
eventually was cracked in Baghdad a
mathematician philosopher called al
Kindi
noticed kind of it's fairly obvious to
us that some letters are more common
than others in English is the most
common letter followed by T followed by
a so if I replace e with a diamond then
you'll see there are lots of diamonds in
the text you'll realize it diameters an
e so then you have to start getting more
complicated then you have to start
saying well how am I going to fool this
this this frequency analysis what's the
difference between cryptography and
encryption
so cryptography is a general field which
provides many functionalities and one of
the functionalities and the most
popularly known one is encryption so
encryption provides you secrecy of your
data but in fact there are more things
that you would want from cryptography
and more things that you would want when
you go to the intranet for example you
would want to be able to identify
yourself properly to your bank account
that cannot be done by encryption you
need something else in order to carry
out that transaction that the bank will
really know that it's time I've been
coming to use my own accounts and not
walls maybe he's better off than me
maybe I'd be doing a better deal but
could be that it isn't so maybe I'll
stick to my bank account but that's one
more thing so that would be offered by
some means of identification another
function that you could have in
cryptography which is not encryption is
that when I receive a letter from you I
want to know that it actually came from
you and that it has not been modified
and you maybe don't want it to be
modified also because maybe if you're
saying I'm gonna hear you want I'll give
you $1,000 for something but then I come
back and it's signed by you and now it's
suddenly a million dollars you're not
gonna be so happy that you have to give
me a million dollars so there are many
many more functions within cryptography
above encryption in addition to
encryption but they all work together
because also when you're sending your
credit card number or your password to
the bank you also want it to be
encrypted so these things really work
together but I think that due to the
history that encryptions been around for
so long and identification
authentication and so on are more things
of an newer era that I think and it's
romantic and they're all these spy
stories and so on so I think that
encryption is our most well known and
representative of our field just just
for the record because we're being taped
here I have known
negating you either a thousand or a
million dollars you wanted to touch base
on this briefly you asked if there were
critical dates when cryptography or the
Cybermen changed or became better I can
think of two in the 1940s and 50s during
World War two when we had to be able to
read foreign codes and the Enigma was
broken and other machines were broken
that was a watershed moment when
mathematics became far more pervasive in
the discipline and that really changed
things from that point afterwards the
next key point was in the 1980s when the
web came and people wanted to do
financial transactions that's when it
became commercially viable it became a
big hit in the commercial arena and the
wide deployment of cryptography became
compelling in the 1980s which drove
changes in the discipline yeah so two
points to interesting I mean you
mentioned the Enigma there obviously
that's quite a well known device
Simon you I believe have will tell us a
little bit of a background to what the
Enigma machine was I think Brian's
absolutely right technology and
cryptography it's one of the old
sessions I think in the whole festival
because cryptography is about
mathematics it's about science it's
about politics it's about privacy it's
about human rights it's about technology
it's a whole mess of different things
and and what you have is something
suddenly the development the Telegraph
you can send messages around the world
instantaneously and encryptions
important because if you're going to
send messages you need to make sure
those messages aren't necessarily going
to be intercepted and stolen with with
radio communication you have that same
situation and and when we get to the
Second World War prior to the Second
World War the Germans realize that that
radios around you can send messages
across battlefields in an instant but if
I can send a radio message across a
battlefield in an instant then the other
side can also tap into those radio
channels so if we're going to have
high-tech radio communication we need to
have high-tech encryption pencil and
paper encryption isn't going to be good
enough and so the Germans actually other
country started working on it as well
but but it was abandoned in Scandinavia
and in America as well the Germans were
the only ones that really took it to its
logical conclusion and invented
something it looks a bit like a
typewriter a big cranky typewriter
keyboard and you type in your message
and out comes gibberish you send the
gibberish over the radio at the other
end somebody's got one of these enigma
machines when these clanky typewriters
they type in the gibberish and the real
original message comes out and the
complexity of the machine guarantees you
your privacy
show us the complexity of the machine
right now I believe that you have a
machine an actual Enigma machine from
and is this an actual this was actually
used during the Second World War this
this machine yeah this one I don't know
a huge amount about I've got one in
London I'm very fortunate have one which
was used in the Second World War and
this one would have been used in the
Second World War
it's an army machine now people in the
audience don't worry you're not gonna
have to Crane you're next we're actually
gonna have a shot of it up here on the
yeah on stage for you so you can see
that this nice wooden box it's pretty
heavy and when you open it up you can
see it does look just like a big
old-fashioned typewriter it's got a
keyboard here and the lamp board is up
here so that's where the gibberish
appears is at the top and if we zoom in
a little bit up to about here if I type
in a letter P let's see what happens the
letter e lights up so P is encrypted as
an e but what's really clever about the
Enigma is if I type in an E again a P
again a V lights up if I type in P again
a Y lights up so we have a random letter
generator the encryption doesn't seem to
follow any kind of pattern and if you
want a good form of encryption that's
what you need a kind of random letter
generator so where is this this
randomness coming from well we can open
up this machine here one thing we can
tell is it's probably built pre-war
because this enamel plate was was only
used pre-war during the war they were
churning out these machines so quickly
they just had a peak paper stuck there
which would have come undone so here's
the lamp board here's a keyboard there
are 26 wires coming out of the keyboard
into the lamps but before they go into
the lamps they go round the side through
these three rotors here and I can take
these rotors out
whoops yeah it's not my machine I'm very
very what about breaking it so we can
see here it's got 26 contact so the 26
wires and the keyboard going to the 26
contacts and they come out at these
contacts here and into those 26 contacts
but in the middle of this object
it's like spaghetti so an a will go in
at 12 o'clock but it might come out as
an F it will go in here as an F it might
come out as a G and so on so the
scrambled wiring inside these rotors is
what leads to the encryption but on its
own that's not enough scrambling is okay
scrambling is simple we can weeks and
scramble without needing a machine what
the Enigma allows us to do let me just
set it up in a certain way I've got it
set up here 21 16 there we go and 11 so
if I do that same process again if I hit
P three times they hit the P first time
the lamp lights up but also you'll have
seen that that rotor moved if that rotor
moves then the key that the wiring goes
in at a different juncture if it goes in
a different Junction it follows a
different electrical path if I type P
again you'll see the lamp light up
different lamp but also the rotor will
move there we go and it's it's this
dynamism for the rotors that gives you
the the complicated encryption and when
that wrote has done a full revolution it
kicks the middle one
when that's done a full revolution it
kicks the end one so it's like a Milo
meter on a car so that's all very well
in terms of creating the the message
what happens at the other end how do you
transfer how do they decode it
okay well first of all you've got to
have a machine so you can't have any
Enigma machine that'll help but but but
with all form of encryption this is
called the algorithm this box of tricks
is the algorithm it does the scrambling
but you have to assume that the other
side know the algorithm they know that
they've got the Machine and the the
Brits the Allies we'd have had one of
these machines and so the real security
relies in how you set up the machine so
and your machine has to be set up in the
same way as mine so for example I've got
three rotors here those three rotors
could be
knocked around three rotors have got six
permutations this rotor before I send
the message can be adjusted to one of 26
positions that can be done to one of 26
positions that to one or twenty six
positions 26 cubed from memory I think
is around 20,000 I could be wrong
multiplied it by the six permutations
gets us to about 100,000 I can also
change where this rotor kicks that rotor
that's another factor of 26 then I went
up to like two and a half million that
one I can vary where that one kicks out
that's another 26 R up to the hundreds
of millions and and it's a bit down here
if we pan down a bit it's what's called
a plugboard here now all this does is it
pull it swaps letters so if I plug a
what Q word W when I type Q the path
follows w's path and when I type W it
follows Q's path now that there are 20
20 cables here in 26 holes and my memory
is it and it may be wrong but I think
there are a hundred million million
different ways to wire up that simple
bit of kids multiplied by the hundred
million or so we had before and your
machine has to be set up exactly the
same way as this so how do we
communicate about how do you tell me
what the configuration of my machine
needs to be in a way that doesn't suffer
the same you know lack of encryption
that we could have had just by
communicating freely in the first place
it's it's kind of crude what you have is
every month you have a bit of paper and
that bit of paper has the settings of
the machine and we might print we may be
in the North African Network Rommel in
his troops and everyone everyone in
Ronald's Network would have one of these
bits of paper and we wake up in the
morning we'd say right it's the third or
fourth of June and we set up our machine
according to that fourth of June recipe
and you've got the same piece of paper
then we can communicate but that bit of
paper has to be biked across the desert
yeah we you know that the guy delivering
it may be incompetent he may be a double
agent he may lose it and this is known
as the key distribution problem and it's
expensive time-consuming and risky but
once you've got that we can I can try
and send a message now
make it quick cuz we're at yeah yeah I
just had a very oh but if let's imagine
I was just sending you a message about
let's say the SS let me just set up
machine here 21 1601 so if I type SS and
s gives me a oh that's why they lost the
war s gives me a let's try it again now
okay excuse me a G and a second s gives
me a J so SS is GJ but to decrypt it I
have to get machine back in the same
space so I have to move that back to
places because that rotors moved and now
if I type in GJ I should get the SS GJ
ah and the J okay the Jake is been said
so 70 years old it's a bit cranky and
it's a bit oxidized but you get the gist
terrific thanks so I'm coming come on
back up that's that's fascinating I mean
what I was alluding to there is you know
a system is only as secure as its
weakest link right I mean you can have a
wonderful encryption and if the means of
of communicating the encryption to the
other party who's going to decrypt it is
insecure if it's a dude on donkey back
riding across the Libyan desert then
that there may be a problem if Churchill
intercepts the dude on the donkey yeah
let's bring that into the modern era
today and let's talk maybe tal about
what is what is the status at the moment
of internet security
what layers of protection do we have
online and are they subject to these
kind of side issues of getting around
the security okay so I'll answer the
first part but I think that would be
better to talk about the attacks oh when
is the outer parts I'm a cryptographer
and he's a [ __ ] the analyst yeah we've
together make this field analyst is a
person who doesn't like being called a
hacker
analysts are also people didn't want to
imply otherwise so this question that
you asked time and exactly about how did
we know how to set the wheels properly
really relates to the era prior to
modern day cryptography where people had
to meet in advance first of all in order
to get the machine they both got it from
the same supplier and then on a daily
basis or on a monthly basis to have this
sheet of paper really to coordinate what
we called the keys there how to set the
wheels at the beginning is the key but
in 1976 we had a huge breakthrough which
was the dawn of modern day cryptography
with a paper that came out by Diffie and
Hellman Hellman was a professor at
Stanford and III was his PhD student and
they said it's complicated it's
physically complicated to meet and agree
on the key maybe we can do something
different and somehow communicate in the
public domain and agree on the key and
they came up with what's called public
key cryptography and public key public
key cryptography and the idea is
basically that instead of the two of us
you and I meeting and agreeing on our
cipher and the key I will have something
which is called the public key and I'll
put it in the public domain and
everybody will be able to access it and
in order to send me an encrypted message
all you need to know is the public key
and I have a corresponding secret key
which I really keep secret in my
computer or maybe on a piece of paper
but of course today on the computer and
I will use it to decrypt and we have a
little pictorial video that will give
explanation exactly of what's happening
let's take a look at that little video
so this is the decryption an example of
how you do public key encryption so what
I do is when I want to set up my system
I choose a public key and a private key
and you can see that they're different
unlike in the case where
Simon showed before when the keys were
the same these are two different keys I
take the public key and I put it in the
public domain everybody can use it and
now Josh comes and he wants to send me
these four encrypted items he puts them
in this box he closes the box and he
locks it with the public key this is a
visual of course it's gonna use an
algorithm as Simon said the boxes the
algorithm there's an algorithm here that
uses the public key I on the other hand
have the public key I'm the only person
like that key sorry and the only person
who has the private key I can open the
box and the items are revealed to me so
can you give us just an everyday example
of what that what that what would that
be we're talking about me logging on to
my bank account are we talking about me
buying something on Amazon what what are
where is the public all right something
that's very important to know is that
today in our current knowledge public
key crypto as opposed to what we call
symmetric key which are these things
that are slightly different public key
is very expensive to carry out well we
have these other encryption schemes
which are symmetric schemes which are
less based on mathematical foundations
but maybe more on voodoo what do you
mean by voodoo explain it now okay so
the public key cryptosystems are based
on some mathematical assumptions for
example that we think that it's
computationally expensive to factor
large numbers we all know how to factor
the number 8 but if you need to factor a
thousand 24 bit key that takes you a
long time and just to remind people who
it's been a while since they were at
math class factoring a number means
figuring out the two numbers that need
to be multiplied together yes for
example let's take 15 it's 3 and 5 right
so it's the prime factors that compose
to this number but if I give you 1,024 a
bit number which is comprised of
multiplying two large Prime's it's hard
to do so public
crypto systems are based on such
assumptions and the end of their hand
symmetric key crypto is not mostly
founded on these mathematical
assumptions but the trade-off is that
it's much faster it really is a huge
difference in time for computing and
encryption but the public key
cryptosystem is opposed to a symmetric
key crypto system so as to your question
when do we use public key what we do is
we do some first operation using the
public key which is expensive we agree
on some key which is appropriate for the
symmetric system and we move to
computing with the symmetric system so
in fact whenever your server that you
your system resides on somehow starts
talking to another server it immediately
does some public key operations mostly
to do a public key agreement and then we
moved to the symmetric ciphers what a
padlock appears on my browser that's
when the padlock you're talking when
you're really what kind that really
means what it means to say is that
encryption is being used so that you'd
know
for example the padlock will always
appear when you're talking to your bank
just so you know that something's
happening that is encryptions being used
so it would have started with a public
key operation and then it would have
moved to a symmetric key operation just
for speed but it would have been
encryption both these things are
encryption or introduction you were
talking about spies and warfare in the
military and and the old-fashioned
encryption only those guys could afford
it because you had to meet yet to print
you had to have these massive
infrastructure's but the beauty of the
mathematics it's being invented now
means that we can all do it and and you
know we live in the information age
we're encrypting stuff whether it's our
health records whether it's buying stuff
on Amazon whether it's we live in
information and we're using cryptography
that is phenomenally sophisticated and
everybody out here it is using virtually
unbreakable cryptography
the hacker has something to say about
that okay and you're supposed to be
under attack I didn't want to get on to
the military aspect so I want to bring
Brian in a moment but or yeah speak to
that so there is a distinction between
hacking and cryptanalysis it's very
similar to some extent so Josh you're
the okay everybody against Joe okay I'll
take it
so hackers are usually working with the
systems or with the people operating the
systems which are if you mentioned
before the weakest link today in 95% of
the cases it's never decrypted it was
broken or the computer security that was
broken it's the users that are
compromised some way or did a mistake or
some problem like that in cryptanalysis
we actually look at the strength of the
algorithm we are not doing the actual
attack it's a difference between saying
this is a good car and actually taking
and taking it in to crush tests so you
take the car and you crush it again and
again again against against the wall and
you say this is a good car versus the
hacker actually takes the car and pushes
it into someone else you're trying to
find faults in in a system for a
beneficial purpose rather than just
trashing them sort of
it depends on how much you're paying
okay Wow she wants one thousand or a
million now you're haggling as well it's
gonna be expensive not for me
Brian I want you to jump in here are we
I mean speak to us a little bit about
the the NSA and what you're really
looking for when you encrypt things and
what the challenges are there well let's
take a large organization then as a
desire to know first of all everything
you've heard so far is at the conceptual
level how things ought to work then
there comes the real world how it really
works the implementation the box that
you saw being worked over there was not
a set of words on paper what wire to
plug to what it was metal and wires in
there and the enigma was not subject to
this but other
logics were it was quite possible that
if you walk up to some boxes in the
field they're doing perfectly good
encryption and you had a hammer and you
whacked the box in just the right spot
the key would automatically reset to a
default key that's very convenient crypt
analysis okay now unfortunately it's
transmitting to a another device which
hasn't been hit yet so what you have to
have is janitor's on staff at both
organizations who go in at midnight and
whack each one and then you can listen
to the line as well as the transmitters
can trigger example and that's what's
called route force analysis you can be a
little more subtle about it and try to
do with mathematics instead in which
case you hit I'm this is all made very
simple and it's not quite this easy but
maybe you don't hit it very hard just
hard enough to break a wire inside but
the same wire is fragile in all of them
so a gentle tap which nobody can hear us
at the door just breaks wires which
still makes it in ciphered but in a
trivial cipher something is very simple
like adding the same number to every
character that goes by so you have a
monoalphabetic substitution the same as
you work in a crossword puzzle in the
newspaper in the morning by hand but it
looks like cypher and it's just those
two parties talking and many military
systems are point-to-point only not two
networks you've got them they're talking
they think they're secure they can see
the cipher written down it looks like
trash you can still break it and read it
these are oversimplified examples but it
all matters what is going on in the
implementation and we in the government
realized that GIS carried hammers and
could do this sort of stuff it was
demonstrated frequently for us in the
military so we spent extra time and
money a box from a large organization
with a desire to no cost money to build
and it took time to design because we
anticipated these sorts of things tried
them out practice them and we attacked
them before we ever released them it
took three to five years design five to
seven years to test and then field test
for another three years before it's
actually sitting track classified
traffic between soldiers in the field
the commercial world doesn't want to pay
that price they want to build very
quickly out of stuff and just you know
let it go and so it makes a lot of fun
they've got good cryptography running
it's on little computers and chips and
they're radiating like swine and all you
have to do is have receivers near the
devices in many cases you can pick up
enough unintended emanations that you
can read the traffic that the guy is
sending and you haven't touched the box
you haven't broken it many cents but
you're still reading the text because it
was not a robust implementation they
didn't spend enough time doing it right
they wanted to meet market pressure make
it cheap my god is it cost twice as much
I will sell my product somebody else
will sell his they faced commercial
pressures and commercial wants the stuff
widely deployed left on desks not locked
up at night that's to our advantage it's
wonderful and unlocked doors and a
nighttime visit there are many ways that
you can get into these systems and the
commercial world isn't willing to set up
- what I'd call the government standard
when we know there's malice and power
out against you and we build a heavy
clunky box and you wait for years to get
it but at least it can stand some abuse
and still be robust and not give away
the store security conference where
somebody was speaking who's worked in
the military and they'd said that
somebody from the neighbouring battalion
had said our secure box is broken and we
want to lock away our hard drive can
that kind of lock away the hard drive in
your secure box he said yes always just
bring it over so later on the day the
battalion officer brought over the the
hard drive is it here it is can you put
it inside your secure box and the guy
said why are you giving me your laptop's
battery every night he's been locking up
the difference between the military
requirements and the commercial
requirements it's true that we are in
the commercial setting piping out these
things much faster and were less
concerned with security but of course my
emails with my daughter's need to be a
little bit less secure than really what
the government is using so there's a
reason for that and I think so the banks
I think really do adhere to a slightly
different standard than maybe Yahoo does
with its emails so doctor thousands of
customers another flaw and it is a flaw
in today's commercial cryptography usage
the military did a limited distribution
of keys Sam
talked about these pieces of paper they
only went to people physically known to
other people that had been vetted and
known to be trustworthy
not many people held those keys in the
commercial arena today there is a
difference between trust and cyberspace
in human space in human space I trust my
doctor to operate on me give me a heart
search and because I understand his
identity who he is I understand his
competency or his role that's a separate
factor and then I understand thirdly his
purpose to help me not to kill me
so in human trust there is identity
competency or role and intent very
important and we make judgments based on
that in the human domain and in the
1980s I went to a doctor I talked to him
he tell me what was wrong I get a
prescription take it to a pharmacist the
pharmacist fulfill it
I'd have basically three to five people
maybe Tennant most who knew my medical
condition that's human trust it is
limited shared pretty well pairwise
between people and though who's going on
and if the doctor messes with me and I
have failed to trust him anymore
I can revoke my trust in him and it's
very hard once you tick me off
to regain my trust in the human domain
what happens in the cyber domain many of
you may have seen this by medical
records I mentioned the prescription in
the 1980s was held by your pharmacist if
you go in 2011 under the same scenario
to the pharmacist and give him your
prescription he fills it you said by the
way I'm going on vacation I'm going to
need an advance a few extra pills before
I come back of the patrician run out
while I'm gone he says well I'm not
allowed to give you advance on
prescriptions anymore but no problem our
chain of pharmacies has a common
database and you go to any pharmacy in
our chain and the city are going on
vacation to on the west coast does have
we have a chain there just go to that
pharmacy and they'll fill your
prescription isn't that convenient
yes very convenient at what cost because
you can go to any pharmacist of that
chain in the nation multiple hundreds so
now who has access to your medical
records multiple hundreds because in
cyberspace it's only the identity very
little do they very seldom do they worry
about competency or role that is being
played by the entity nor the intent if
you merely have a identity your trusted
into the database you go
in human space I trust tall tall trust
sing therefore perhaps I should trust
sing not necessarily that's a separate
human interaction in cyberspace
if computer a trust computer being
computer being trust computers see then
a trust see it's transitive in
cyberspace but not in human space there
it believe me this is a hard point you
get it across very carefully
that's a cognitive dissonance between
what we as humans expect of trust and
what the machines today in the
commercial arena are prepared to deliver
I mean is there anything rich is should
we be concerned about this about the
subsuming of of trust by computer
systems and networks by the replacement
of this kind of human interaction with
our information being online and being
accessible in that way is there anything
we can do about it if we are concerned
or we just have to get used to this new
reality there are mechanisms that can
how that you got them yet there are
mechanisms that can be pursued this in
the research community not yet Latour
because cyber trust is only been around
basically in this widespread commercial
deployment arena for twenty years like
any 20-year old its full of spunk thinks
it knows everything and won't listen
okay what if I don't want to be able to
get my prescription filled in LA when
I'm on holiday yeah even before you ask
they want to say something that I think
there is a huge difference between Brian
and me I don't want to speak for the
other people in this panel but I think
that you and your profession you've been
really focused on security at a very
very high level but this issue with the
prescription and still until I sat here
now I was never scared now I'm petrified
because I see it from a completely
different point of view through our life
experiences than our even though we both
do research in exactly the same field
I want to much more enjoy going to LA
and getting my prescriptions filled and
I don't carry that much it might be a
mistake and I maybe I shouldn't say it
in this audience especially since I'm a
cryptographer but I really do feel that
I personally and I think many people
give up a lot on the security in order
enjoy the benefits but you don't have to
it could be better
I don't think sorry just clarify that
for me why do I not have to if I'm gonna
be able to go to California and get my
prescription filled then there has to be
a network of systems between all of
those pharmacies doesn't there and then
no matter how good the encryption what
can be the pharmacist is still gonna
have the authority to be able to log in
and see that I need viagra give me just
a moment on this intrusion either that I
dart either very prescribed either a
viagra or a prescription for a vial
sexually transmitted disease you just
assume your friends didn't know you had
and that's the risk in some sense but a
quick and easy fix we did not talk about
hashing functions but it's a type of
cryptography the original pharmacist can
put my records in the computer put down
my prescriptions it could I live in but
he doesn't enter my name he types the
name and address all that sort of stuff
in he thinks he is but what the database
stores is a hash a cryptographic
combination of it they cannot be backed
out trying to cover the data so I can go
to the west coast it says I need you to
fulfill my prescription he says okay
what do you know what's your name and he
typed my name in the machine and as long
as I give him the exact name I gave the
original pharmacist show he might you
know they have to be careful on this
because one character off and you're
messed up but my name of the dress can
go in
it'll be hashed by his machine and the
database is searched for the matching
hash he can find my prescription it can
give it to me but anybody else reading
that database who doesn't know my name
to begin with cannot find me and HIPAA
regulations are trying to drive toward
these types of solutions that still
preserve human concept of trust one
pharmacist are just those who I actually
give my name to face to face can get to
my records nobody else can jump in or
were a bit tangential here so I do wanna
move on but we just haven't done it I
just want to break a system that's my
job I'm being overly trivial I know it's
breaking I want it to be simple so yeah
so if you simplify it yeah you can break
it and especially in this case because
in theory the pharmacist at the other
side could just try all the names of the
people in the US there are only 300
million give or take and if you have
reference you're laughing but if you
take a very fast computer trying three
hundred million names just to identify
who of your neighbors is
STD or happens to be a sex offender or
any of these things you can easily do
that so it's not a real it doesn't give
you the real privacy the thing is that
people don't really want to pay for
privacy I mean I'm not talking about
convenience in the case of traveling to
a different place and having your
prescription filled I'm talking about
simpler things how many of the audience
have Facebook accounts how many people
on Facebook how many people publish
their whereabouts on first Square
Foursquare and that sort of stuff
how many people use the places feature
on Facebook so whatever they will check
into someplace people don't become the
mayor of farmville and buy a bunch of
sheep yeah I'm still trying to figure
out how to become that yeah I own I
heard that you get three keys in
exchange for being the mayor in any case
people are willing to trade their
privacy in their security for very
little there was an exercise than
several years ago I think it was in
London in the city where people were
walking around and offering candies for
passwords and this is the City of London
Renata babies for candy a candy bar for
your password to be a password yeah your
Facebook password no for your real
password at your London bank for your
ATM PIN code no for the they went to
city personnel working for banks right
the city is like Wall Street in London
yes sir yeah yeah Wall Street yeah you
go to the Wall Street and you tell them
I will give you a candy bar in exchange
for your password into the mainframe of
the company you're working for well how
many people do you think gave a password
for a candy we're talking about people
working at the city earning billions of
whatever currency they're using over
there and given life given what they
managed to do to the world in 2008 I
would imagine they probably don't have
the intellect of do they probably all
failed that right mentioning that it was
not our cryptanalysis had nothing to do
with the Wall Street so most of them
gave more than 90% gave their passwords
right in extreme candy bar this is back
go to the cognitive dissonance as
talking about people don't understand
cyber
and it's connected risks yeah they only
understand human domain stuff that they
see on the street everything we know not
to trust in a large city in a small town
you get away with a little bit more
small town communities grew up over time
we have to grow up to have a safely live
in cyberspace and what mechanisms we
need we have not yet done it offer some
reassurance for me at nobody else I mean
you're all in the biz I so I've written
about cryptography but you're in the
business of protecting and checking that
these things work and trying to trash
them and guarding top-level government
secrets and so on
and the kind of day-to-day interactions
that we might have you know so buying
stuff on the internet and so on our
credit card details are relatively safe
and I'd say relatively I mean your
turret is if you ring somebody up and
you give your credit card number over
the phone
you don't necessary know who that person
is you don't know what their ulterior
motive is you don't know what's going on
there so there's always a listening yeah
who's missing there's always going to be
a ring that was your job right Brian I'm
officially never in the US but yeah
given the alternatives the sort of
systems that we use on a day to day
level are fairly robust every so often
we see a scandal interpret and it's very
high-profile it's the newspapers I saw
but in general these these in one way we
could say we're living in a golden age
of cryptography that these systems I can
send you an email and we can we don't
have to have met because we have this
wonderful public key encryption system
and all of the worlds and I could
download free encryption software that
would do this and all of the world's
computers working for a billion years
would not be able to crack this code let
me just read one quick anecdote to that
which is that the other day and I hadn't
didn't think of this until you just
mentioned it someone called me on the
phone an unknown number and said with
whom Oh speaking and I said Josh Zepps
and Oh mr. zaps this is so-and-so from
Chase Chase Manhattan Bank can I just to
verify your identity can I just
verify your address and and bank account
number I was like no well no of course
not I don't even know who you are it was
like oh we just have to discuss your
account details we'll find another way
to discuss my damn account details so
Brian a nine percent will fall for that
not just 90 percent is in your case now
he was probably legit right but no he
meant almost all banks train their
employees so tell me why at least a
flawed a flawed system of cryptology is
not better than this than that system
because they don't know it's flawed
that's the risk I'm willing to accept
risks I know and understand when I use
something that I think is secure and
it's a piece of cheese and I wind up
dead that's not fun simon's question
relating the cryptography so total dough
is as much as we know how we have these
assumptions and it is hard to break the
crypto usually systems are not broken by
breaking the crypto it's usually broken
but by the things around by the
implementation by the guy riding on the
donkey and giving out the the keys so
there's more information flowing around
the world today than ever before
and and it's encrypted better than ever
before but there's always gonna be that
tiny fraction because there's so much of
it there's also gonna be quite a bit
it's badly encrypted and that's the kind
of thing that the NSA will thrive well I
agree with everything you're saying on
the government side on the commercial
side I would say it's more is flowing on
the commercial side than on government's
almost all of it is encrypted and almost
all of it badly not by the technology by
the human processes using King and
inadequate protections it don't even vet
the people that you hand the keys to you
just get his name and address you do not
do a background investigation that sort
of 90% of the crypto in the commercial
arena is crap not because of the
technology because of the usage
parameters the way the humans use it can
you give us some I at the end it's back
of the book the Diamondback cryptography
I had 10 coded messages and whoever
could break all 10 coded messages would
win $20,000
and the message is group A's for the so
there were technical increasingly hard
and it took over a year for people to
break them and eventually a group of
Swedish jugglers won the competition
there's an odd reason they were
cryptographers and engineers and
computer scientists and did you give
them the twenty thousand cryptid account
they couldn't access I tried to encrypt
the check but I went to Stockholm and I
gave it to how I made the code they gave
to how they broke the code and they
explained to me they see something
really interesting that the final stage
which is the really tough stage involves
something called Triple DES or Triple
DES means you encrypt with one key you
decrypt but with the wrong key which
makes even more messed up and then you
re encrypt with the first key and it's
it for not effectively unbreakable and
then I weakened it in a secondary way to
make it a fair test and and what they
pointed out to me was that I'd encrypted
with the right key then I decrypted with
the same key which got me back to square
one and then I'd encrypted with this
under key so what I'd done was giving
them a really trivial code that they
could have broke up within 24 hours now
it took them over a year to do it
because they didn't think I could be
that stupid what happens that humans are
involved at the end and doing the last
things and instead of using three
different keys used one key twice and
one key so it is affected with single
DES instead of triple des and with
unique my machine they they make most
pretty pretty pretty good you know the
Germans pioneered it and so they made
mistakes and the Allies and the American
and the Brits improved on it but it's a
pretty good machine but what you'll see
in terms of the Allies cracking the
Enigma was that the Allies had big
problems cracking the naval Enigma
partly because they had time to encrypt
it properly they were onboard a
submarine or u-boat they had space their
time but in the battlefield people would
rush they reuse keys they type patterns
and they'd make mistakes and and and
that's why the Enigma are
the code was broken routinely human
error not not the machine error or yes I
mean I want to also move on to like you
know this you you're kind of geeky
specifics or about how we break the I
say that with the greatest respect and
the greatest honor for geeks everywhere
I'm afraid geek myself but you know what
is the system what we're using can you
explain 1024 bit are we ever gonna be
able to crack it where are we at yes no
and maybe earlier valve was mentioning
the fact that public key cryptography is
based on mathematical foundations and
we're doing voodoo I'm dealing with the
symmetric key stuff which is a slightly
different then you take the data that
you have to encrypt you throw it into
some hat you throw in some operations
you shift it you rotate it you do many
things and you get something out of the
Hat
hopefully it's well encrypted but as
Brian said sometimes it's not and we're
actually trying to break these things
and find out if it's secure enough or
not and it really depends and I think
that today as mentioned before we came
to the physician to the status that the
security itself is good enough most of
the time the problem is not the probe is
not the algorithm it's the way the
algorithm is used and it's the user so
coming back to this point I want to I
want to just find some examples okay we
keep coming back to this point that the
the math is good enough that the
encryption is good enough the algorithms
are good enough but that it falls down
on the implementation can someone give
us a couple of really concrete examples
on how that happens so there is a car
alarm thing you just got a car before
actually it's also used in them garages
to open and close the door yep which
uses a cipher called key lock no it's a
cipher that was designing the 80s in
South Africa not so great cipher but not
so bad and it was held secret and
recently it was published and once it
was published we try to analyze it and
we found some theoretical attacks and
even implemented them and well they're
not that theoretical but everything
works fine and then you open the
protocols to see how it's used and all
the garage openers use the same key now
not necessarily immediately so just to
relax everybody who has a garage door up
in their door is New York City no it has
a garage door or a car yeah that's the
problem for giving examples in New York
but the thing is that there is a system
behind it take some generic key and uses
it in some modification in all devices
so once you finds the generic key then
you know everything it's not a bad idea
do you mean that you would literally be
able to take that someone else's garage
door opener and open your own door I
wouldn't even have to take his garage
door opener I will just be able to
listen to one communication that he's
doing with his garage and singing the
frequency of his garage door and they
would be able to enter his garage your
garage everybody's garage can I follow
that yeah similar example many people
are buying modern cars these days that
have key fobs instead of mechanical keys
you put in a lock and turn you just walk
up to your car if you within two feet
the car unlocks for you because the car
talks to the fob anybody in the audience
like that Prius cars anything built
since 2009 typically has these sorts of
things almost all Nissan's now am I like
that and it's very convenient it's
wonderful but there's an attack against
it which is absolutely downright
stupidly cheap and easy okay I need to
be near my car but two guys who are
standing nearby watching observe this
and one of them sees me start to walk
away from the car he follows me the
other guy walks up to my car they're
carrying each a small radio the radios
are close to my father in my pocket and
close to the car the car talks across
that radio link through the radios not
knowing their radios in play if thinks I
am still near the car because me fifty
feet away is picked up by Radio
transmitted no keys need to be known
they could be all robust no problem but
the actual key I steal midstream and
pass through the other radio which is
within two feet of the car by you know
doing the round-trip timing it knows I'm
near the door unlocks the thief gets in
goes my car cars are being stolen that
way today
would there be a way I mean surely
there's a way of encrypting the the
message in the in the key fob such that
it can't be sent over radio waves like
that simply now once you start saying
surely can't of course there many ways
you can't they didn't write they didn't
think the problem food to begin with in
every era and every so for example in
the 50s and Brian may know more about
this but there's a full hunk breakable
Co called a one-time pad it is utterly
unbreakable it is mathematically
logically in every possible way you
cannot break a one-time pad because
every element of the message is randomly
changed and you can't unpack randomness
now the recipe for changing every
element of the message has to be a
random sequence of letters
that's the one-time pad you can only use
it once because we use it twice it's no
longer random because someone else has
used it so to make the one-time pad
cipher work you have to generate huge
amounts of random sequences and the
Russians were using one-time pads and I
feel the Americans and the Brits and
everybody else using one-time pads but
they met the mistake that the Russians
made was in order to generate these
one-time pads they would just randomly
type on letters on a keyboard but if you
look at what I'm doing it's not random
because I'm going left right left right
immediately
the randomness is being lost and that
slight loss of randomness was enough for
the NSA to attack Russian ciphers during
the Simon can you quickly tell that
story about Fineman do you know the
story I'm talking about about richard
fineman breaking the safe i'm trying to
remember how he did it now he was gosh
he was guessing was he guessing or was
he always looking for the last element
of the of the rotor as well it's it's
about getting yourself inside their head
of the other person yeah so with so what
if you've got an unbreakable code if
there are two people in the back of you
but absolutely unbreakable code what I
can do is monitor your traffic analysis
so if you send one message on a Monday
one on
day one on a Wednesday 10:00 on a
Thursday I know something bigs gonna
happen on a Friday I don't know what
your messages are but I'm beginning to
glean something by getting inside your
head what you might then do is send ten
messages every day because you're
getting inside my head now and you
didn't use the same quote of messages
every day so your traffic is flat hmm
but once then if you're going to have to
create these fictitious messages then
you're going to have to start sending
probably random messages or gobbledygook
messages or patterned messages and
that's what they did with the Enigma and
that's one of the ways he Enigma was
cracked so it's like poker isn't it I
mean what are they thinking about what
I'm thinking that I'm that they're
thinking that I'm thinking their thing
it's technology its economics its
politics and now it's psychology and
math and technology or how do you let's
let's get away from this non code
related stuff how do you actually break
a code I mean let's forget the human
error let's get straight to the math how
you break a code okay you take this big
and you're 30 to the left now the thing
is as follows we actually don't break
the code we try to analyze how secure
they are so we take the cipher is there
a difference sorry
is there a difference yes breaking the
code is usually when you have some
ciphertext some cryptogram and you want
to know what's been sent there for
example you see a message from put into
medev and you want to say to understand
exactly what's going on there
breaking the cipher is actually
analyzing its security what we're doing
is analyzing the security breaking the
code is what the Friends of Brian were
used to doing because he's didn't do any
of this I think it's partly but we can
all have unbreakable codes we can all we
can it's not a problem
it's wired that we'll accept they're
always going to be constraints they're
gonna be financial constraints or any
software constraints Hardware
constraints the speed of encryption you
require and the volume of data are you
encrypting film streams or you're just
encrypting audio and so it's about
building a system that's good enough and
you want to test that it's strong enough
without having a breakthrough yeah Brian
is it sobbing there there is no such
thing as an break
cryptography all that you can ever hope
for his cryptography that is good enough
for the mission because it's damn hard
to build perfect stuff and it costs too
much even in the military they'll back
away from it they go for good enough
does this come down to basically how
long it takes you to break a code I mean
ultimately I suppose if you could keep
crunching the numbers for millions and
millions of years then a hundred
thousand monkeys tapping around on a
thousand typewriters would break the
code right I mean is that the part of it
is brute force exhaustion is what you're
talking about but back to ORS work
typically he knows the hardware of the
machine
he gets that in some fashion and he
studies that and he can invent his own
plaintext to put in and get out of his
own ciphertext and look are there any
correspondences and can work with that
information you need some leg to stand
on if you give me a message and ciphered
by machine I've never seen it is so much
harder than you if you give me a message
in ciphered by an enigma or something I
know the schematic for does that I know
how to skate straight it so offers in
the so Brian was mentioning again the
price and this is one of the reasons the
DoD's buying toilet seats for nine
hundred dollars because they need to
practice them in nine hundred dollars
toilet seats toilet toilet six hundred
dollars if it's only a Defense
Department so because they it's the same
process they have to test it for that in
that many years before they ship them
around it's the same thing because you
need they need the assurance casado
weather is the day are they buying $600
toilet seats yeah they used to but it
stays down when the bomb goes off nearby
you're not throwing off
Wow the end is one hell of a Mexican
meal
[Laughter]
okay that's okay
the thing here is that if you look very
carefully at the end as Brian said there
is cryptography which is good enough for
the mission and there is such a thing
from mathematical point of view
unbreakable
the one-time pad that Simon just
mentioned is completely from a
thematical point of view unbreakable no
matter what you will do assuming and
this is we have a big field in
cryptography called provably provable
security we can prove to you that the
cipher is secure under the following
assumptions and usually it's just like
commercials for medications it will
improve your sex life under the
following condition you should not take
alcohol if you not do that you should
not do that the same thing the
mathematical problem should be hard it's
secure as long as we don't know how to
find prime factors as long as you pick
your keys correctly as long as you don't
disclose the keys in some way for
example there used to be a machine that
used to as part of the initialization
process to broadcast the key somehow I'm
not going to enter which system but it
would broadcast the key so the
encryption would start like sending the
key and then they encrypt the data okay
in one word right let's come back to
something key going on here though and
knowing you have a hard problem that is
ephemeral in itself let's take a look at
RSA the RSA crypto cryptographic process
we talked about before which depends on
being able to factor large numbers since
the time of Gauss has been known that
factoring large numbers is hard so there
are say was first offered they said 512
bit numbers should be very difficult and
they were with the mathematical
competence at that time and they gave a
contest you know saying can you crack
this thing and it was eventually crack
because mathematicians then started
paying attention to the fact that well
used to factoring was just a
mathematical game played among
mathematicians and it didn't really have
any real world impact as far as how fast
kind of factored really big number
so they hadn't done the work to see how
hard is it so they started doing the
work over the past 20 years on that
problem and they made tremendous
mathematical approaches in theory only
far exceeding Gauss's ability to discuss
how to factor it's still a hard problem
but not near as hard as we thought it
was because we hadn't worked on it very
hard but the mathematicians have worked
much harder over the past few decades
and now RSA is not considered secure
unless you've got about three thousand
bits are more in the parameter size not
512 six times bigger okay it's a huge
difference between what was secured 20
years ago and what is secured today and
not because the algorithm or Hardware
changed because our mathematical
competence grew over that time so I mean
I want to come to Thailand do you just
want to finish that Thor just to go back
a couple of steps just that we've taught
that public key a couple of times and we
saw the video I mean the way I think
about public key is if I want send you a
message I put it in a box and and I pad
lock it and I send you the precious
objects in a box
maybe you can't open it because I've got
the key that's that that's our key
distribution problem I have to meet you
give you the key get a courier to get
the key to you but the the way public
key cryptography is there are different
ways of thinking about one one way we
could do it is I paddle up the box I
send it to you you can't open it you put
your own padlock on it send it back to
me I've got a padlock two padlocks on
the box I can take mine off send it back
to you there's only one padlock left
it's your padlock you can open it you
can open the box we've avoided any key
distribution that the even smarter way
to do it is that you make a thousand
padlocks and and they're all open and I
just go to my local post office I say
can I have one of Josh's padlocks I take
it off the CEO offer itself I can snap
it shut because anybody can close a
padlock I don't need a key for that send
it to you you can open it could was york
padlock in the first place you've always
had the key
and that's what we're doing here when
you when you send something to Amazon
your browser goes off and says to the
virtual post office can I have Amazon's
padlock we can shut it because anyone
can shut the padlock goes to Amazon only
they can open it now what is this
padlock it's not a real padlock it's a
mathematical padlock and when you think
about what it's a padlock it's a device
which is very easy to close but it's
very very hard to open yeah in life
there are many things that you can
easily switch on a light switch you can
easily switch it off even easy opening
doors need to close at all but padlocks
are different they only go one way
they're very hard to go the other way
it's by mixing paint you can mix yellow
and blue paint to get green but you
can't unmixed green to get yellow and
blue so you need a mathematical
operation that's easy to do very very
hard to undo and that's where this
faction comes in
I can I can think of it too I'm gonna
multiply two numbers in my head and I
get the arter 323 the trivial answers
can anybody think of the two numbers
that multiply to get 323 one do that
thinking about thinking about that I
would like to comment on the RSA Rivest
Shamir and Adleman
it was a truly great piece of work
because this one wavefunction which is
the key thing in public key cryptography
allows we on earth to talk to Martians
if they live there without ever being
able to travel between the planets you
could not do that with standard
cryptography somebody have to carry the
physical piece of paper you're talking
about before for the Enigma and deliver
it to them something physical had to
happen not necessary PKI it is brilliant
work in this regard yeah and it allows
firm attribution who actually created
the message and sent it in the first
place only they had the key that would
allow them to lock it that particular
way so improve in court who said what
and that allows you to have mutually
suspicious partners to business
transactions where in the military the
stuff that I have build by definition
you trust the general he said go do
something you did it it was a command
and control structure one way down
public-key cryptography is of no value
to them but they're mutually suspicious
piers it's gold because you can take it
to a judge and said he signed this
contract and I can prove he signed it
because only he had the capability to do
so and the security of that relies on
the author and I assume you would have
got it was nineteen times seventeen now
I can do that really quickly because I
say nineteen times seventeen well 20
times seventeen is 340 take away 17 is
323 so I can do that in a second but a
few hundred people over the course of
half a minute can't go backwards on our
cut on our calculators we have
multiplication keys
we don't have factoring backwards keys
and the bigger the numbers the harder it
is the bigger the numbers the more
secure it is and the question is how big
do the numbers need to be not just for
today but you know your contract may be
lasting maybe a private secure
confidential contract last 100 years if
you were agents in the field and you
want their identity secret you've got to
protect them for their lives maybe for
their children's lives I thought so
you've got a project into the future and
that's where this payoff is between and
the bottle is saying that you need the
security to be appropriate for the
mission at hand so in fact if you are
encrypting your spine names and you want
them to be secure for twenty years
you're looking for different encryption
and security I mean the size of the keys
that you would take as opposed to the
emails that you're sending today and
you'd really don't care if they're found
and encrypted in a year so your levels
of security vary by the mission at hand
which the crypto needs to be addressing
so in designing a good system you have
to think about all these things together
and really target we really need to move
on Brian but very very quickly
I just go to the future but to be
careful on this RSA has changed over
time as we mentioned we still think of
mathematics is something fixed and rigid
it's not it also grows over time so the
problem today is hard enough but in 20
years it may not be hard enough anymore
because new mathematics has been created
so cryptography is very tough to do
right in the long term because we cannot
project how clever future mathematicians
will be RSA Rivest Shamir Adelman public
it's all the same thing pretty much all
the same thing and for two thousand
years people thought it was impossible
they thought you cannot I can't send you
a message if I've never met you
it's just fundamental you cannot do it
and yet the maths it's a few hundred
years old the maths was around us all
the time but we couldn't make that
conceptual leap it goes back to the
maths of fair mar and Chinese remainder
theorem and it's it's a you just don't
know what the math that's that the math
is the most shocking thing out there I
could continue on that forever but I
want to look look to the future you know
the world is becoming increasingly
digitized as I said in the introduction
we're looking at the possibility of
online voting we're looking at having
our medical records online we're looking
at increasingly cloud computing you know
I'm starting to store my documents and
things not in a localized computer but
in a cloud that I can access from
anywhere privacy is a huge issue and
will only become more so tal your
research group has had some
breakthroughs can you can you speak to
the breakthrough that I assume you know
that I'm referring to so really as Josh
was saying the cloud is becoming
something that we're gonna be using
maybe it's gonna take us time maybe we
won't be using it but our kids will more
extensively and for example one thing
that we'd want to use the cloud for is
for taking our data and storing it in
some remote server like Amazon or Google
they have their servers for storing data
but we'd want to protect it because we
don't want people working at Amazon
readings were our stuff so most likely
we will encrypt our data and in fact if
you're practicing proper cloud use you
should encrypt the data prior to sending
it out to the cloud so now there's a
question of what's the usability of that
data so I stored and stored data and now
I want to retrieve some of the files but
I don't know which files I want to
retrieve that I'm being audited for my
2004 tax year I need all the files that
are stored there on the server that have
things that relate to my 2004 tax year
so of course I could ask the server to
send me
everything i'll decrypt everything and
then i'll find the appropriate files
first of all the tax return then the
statements from the bank etc but this is
very highly expensive in computing in
traffic and so on so the question is can
I ask the server who can't see the data
and can't read it because it's encrypted
and it's protected to do some
computation on that encrypted data and
send me back the files that I need and
this is a question that was
interestingly enough introduced when
public key crypto became reality in the
beginning of modern day cryptography in
in the 70s of course they didn't know
about the cloud let alone about they
didn't know about the internet or
anything but they were thinking about
databases and they had this question and
interestingly enough as Brian said we
never know what future mathematicians
are gonna be thinking but a guy who
works in my group and solved this
question which was open for 30 years of
whether we can somebody can process
encrypted data for us and send us the
answers that we need without ever
knowing what the data was what my
question was or anything and this has
been a huge breakthrough that was
introduced in 2009 unfortunately you
still can't have it from your cloud
provider this is a difference between
theory and practice this is a
theoretical result it tells us yes we
can but it doesn't yet tell us exactly
how we can do it in a way that we can do
it quickly
you mean currently if you send that
query to the server for your 2010 return
I think you'll answer the question in
about 2030 so not so great but hopefully
this is where we're standing now with
respect to our research really trying to
bring it from the theory to the practice
I mean it's been interesting in
cryptography I think that many times
there were things that first appeared as
more theoretical result just proofs of a
feasibility that we can in fact do
things and
later on they were brought in to really
being able to do them and to providing
them as services to the cryptids and
community which is all of us this new
meth know she's talking about is
compelling theoretically it's not ready
yet for real-time but it is very hopeful
and I hope there'll be a unintended
spin-off from it because as I mentioned
earlier the real risk today is that
commercial cryptography is trusting too
much too widely too quickly not in the
consort with human concepts of trust
being limited and local this may be a
not only a way to do things privately in
the cloud without others seeing it but
of being able to localize somewhat and
pull back from this everybody gets to
see scenario that we're playing with
commercially today and that's what's
really scaring the hell out of me today
and I think is a real risk that we all
face your nets are staying up and
running beautifully not because of the
competence of your IT staff the hackers
know how to get you they could crash the
world economy today if they wished true
statement I'm sorry
why don't they why kill the Golden Goose
they're milking enough money out of us
with their crime techniques and malware
and everything else it isn't worth their
time but if they wanted to they could or
some nation-state not worried about
money staying up wanted to go after
another group of nation-states
we're living in a far too exposed
posture today we're taking too much risk
well that's what I want to talk about I
mean assuming that people are acting
self-interested huge dicks assuming that
people are acting self-interested Lee
perhaps they wouldn't bring it bring it
all down but you know I've heard
increasing warnings about about cyber
terrorism and things like this so you
know non-state actors who really have no
interest in seeing the system sustained
who could potentially hack into nuclear
power plants hack into the rail system
hack into the air traffic control system
when it won't too many words potentially
drop it right is okay so in in a world
that's increasingly networked where were
you know you would only have to bring
down all every the electricity supply to
every hospital in America I mean we just
you allow your brain to start going
these places and it's pretty clear that
this is an awesome tool in the arsenal
of people who would wish to do us ill as
a former person who was charged with
preventing their how optimistic are you
and what can we do
I don't sleep well at night I really
don't only got three hours sleep last
night facing some of the problems like
this for another client it is difficult
for those of you really concerned in
what to pursue it's a me say jury
briefed Congress in 2007 on potential
cyber risks he ran a group of 30 people
that did a study that felt they could
crush the US economy stopped the cars
from moving the gas from flowing
electricity from coming to our homes and
stuff for up to 30 days how much would
it cost to repair section attack about
three years five hundred million dollars
he briefed them in 2007 more than three
years have passed I am convinced the
arsenal of weaponry to take us down
exists today and could be fired at any
moment all it requires is intent so you
have to behave much nicer on the world
stage and we have to get our act clean
before somebody gets nasty enough to do
it and so assuming but let's imagine
that the year were 1999 and we were
sitting here talking about the potential
for you know terrorist attack on New
York City using rudimentary techniques I
mean you know god forbid that this
should be something that's coming down
the pike but what would your your
professional recommendation be that we
can actually do to head that off before
it happens that particular event which
is localized small group of people
plotting on their own it's very
difficult without conceptualizing that
risk and trying to think what types of
groups who should i watch that sort of
stuff very hard to find them you know
this is outside of normal Ken the tooth
you know the 2001 event after the fact
it is so obvious but before the fact it
was not and now we've gone through the
fact and now it's sadly part of everyday
stuff and putting plate mechanisms in
place still imperfect to cause it from
happening again I see that saying
sometimes you can't visualize what you
don't yet anticipate and you wind up
getting it in the shorts or do you have
any thoughts about this what should we
that we'd be doing to protect ourselves
well given the fact that it would reduce
my control over in the US I object this
but seriously though you can change the
system slowly and it's actually most
mostly education I mean people are
unaware so people will break into my
Facebook account
what's the worst thing that can happen
so today people break into your Facebook
Facebook account they put a status
notice I'm stuck in London please send
me some money and your friends see this
on Facebook and they know it's coming
from you and they send money to this
person who is stuck in London
however this guy is not really in London
is probably somewhere in Moscow or st.
Petersburg or in Shanghai getting good
money from your friends and people tend
to use the same passwords all over the
places so how many of you have the same
package just about to ask that how many
people here have more than to have the
same password on more than one website
yeah thank you very much I appreciate
without wanting to end on a worrisome
note let's talk about let's talk about
online voting I mean I think back to the
2004 I think back to the 2004 election
and the the deep old machines and things
you know people were worried about
there's no paper trail and they could
just be corrupt and all this kind of
stuff how far away are we from from
online voting will we will it ever be
sufficiently secure that we can have
faith there are systems that do online
voting I want to see the DeBolt is not
an online okay so there are systems that
you can do online voting off like addcom
you can't go there so we cryptographers
we belong to an association which is
called the international association of
Cryptologic research research i see and
and we as an organisation had a huge
discussion whether we should vote move
to online voting for our internal voting
and and it was decided that we would
vote for our members and directors not
for the members with the directors and
the president and our question ballots
that we had through an online system
and in fact for the first time this past
year we voted online but it has been the
recommendation of this organization and
they came out in the acidity they
despite that we're saying that we should
vote for this election which is of
course not that important that we should
vote online that they're not
recommending at this point to move to
online voting for political elections
and so on also you have to think that
our organization it's a little harder to
vote because we're dispersed all over
the world so voting online there's a
little easier but basically what we're
saying if there's still a capability to
go to the polling station then at this
time this is what still should how far
off you say at this time how far off is
it and then I'll come to Brighton and
know that prophets was prophecy was
given to the fools so okay Brian I'm
foolish online voting will be good
enough to the extent that will be no
worse than paper voting today when the
cemetery's walk out and vote within 5 to
10 years if we have the appropriate
intent and drive for it interesting
Simon do you want to it's just I think
online voting encapsulate the four
points at the tower mentioned earlier on
if I vote I want my vote to be secret
that's the encryption I want to make
sure that my vote for party a doesn't
get changed into a vote for party to
that's integrity of the message three
the person at the other end needs to
know that it's me that's voters that
they can tick me off a list and four I
want to make sure that later on you
can't say you never receive my vote it's
a non repudiation so all of the elements
in cryptography are embedded in this
question of online voting there is a
fifth element which is the privacy so
people the person who takes that your
name off the list does not know who you
voted for yeah and this is a very
important problem we have you're sort of
a problem that for once you need the
ability to only for approved people to
vote so you need the ability to identify
who voted you also need the ability to
identify who got the votes and you need
the ability to not be able to connect
the dots
somehow but I think that online voting
is a big problem especially in countries
where democracy actually matters there
is a big group as opposed to the other
countries where democracy doesn't matter
you know the voting in China are usually
very accurate and you can predict the
outcome very easily the problem here is
that first of all in the u.s. we have
the National Institute of Standards and
Technology working on voting machines
and voting and all these things and the
main problem there is that currently the
system of the u.s. is not that great
sorry to say that you have absentee
votes in many countries you don't have
absentee votes in Israel you have to
actually come into the ballot box to
vote and absentee votes are really great
they're really useful when you're on the
road but on the other hand what prevents
me from you know asking your absentee
vote and I think that there are reports
of people doing that or I could be
easily coerced because you see me
kicking off I mean one of the problems
we have with a voting is the fact that
currently when you enter a ballot box
with the curtain that nobody sees what
you're voting you can afterwards go back
to the person who threatened to kill you
unless you vote for candidate a and say
well I voted for candidate a but I said
I'm sorry I couldn't bring you in with
me but when you have an absentee vote
you know I'm holding again to sign a gun
- Simon please stick a and then he sends
it off the fact that so far the system
works is just that nobody really cared
which is usually why one of the reasons
we still have critical network
infrastructure which sucks because
nobody really tried so far to break it
down but the moment somebody will
necessity is the mother of improvement
invention I suppose what's the
cryptographic development that you think
is coming down the pike that will be the
the most important and we only have a
couple of minutes left but Simon you're
good at thinking to the future and
speculative wildly I mean if the future
may already be here I mean the public
industry research that's going on and we
kind of know what's happening there but
then we don't know what's going on
inside the NSA or in Britain we have
GCHQ we talk to that public key
cryptography which was developed in the
mid 70s late 70s what we didn't know
until very recently was that that was
all invented in the very early 70s in in
Cheltenham just outside well just as
like Bristol in England but the gch
who invented it kept it top-secret and
the scientists who did all of that work
got no credit for a well over a decade
because it was confidential so there may
be amazing ideas developed in top secret
labs sometimes say that the science of
secrecy is by its very nature gonna be
secret so the big developments may be
out there but we may not know them yet
one idea that is out there that is more
public in something called quantum
cryptography and the idea of quantum
cryptography is you send your messages
using individual photons and and such
fundamental particles in quantum physics
when you look at an object you change it
so if an eavesdropper looks at the
object we know that's happened and so we
know that somebody's tapping our
messages and we can stop that
communication and quantum cryptography
when when I wrote about it 15 years ago
seem like a fairy story but now there
are spin-off companies technology
companies it will sell you quantum
cryptographically and the Norwegians
broke it two years ago these dropped on
the kwame channel which met all the
requirements except it was not robust
enough mei-mei everybody be private safe
and secure in their lives please join me
in thanking all of the panelists this
afternoon
[Music]
thank you everybody
[Music]